in parts 1 & 2 of this series we learned
about Alaska Natives fight for their
land in this part we'll hear from a
young artist who's reviving a cultural
tradition to heal from generations of
trauma since a long long long time ago
before all of these things have shifted
and changed we've had tattoos when I do
a tattoo on somebody that powerful
strength that comes from our ancestors
shows through and you could see just the
strength come back into that person vana
ku knocks it Nozomi Laura I see a new
fellow rumba my name is Cunha and I come
from Nome Alaska and I am in effect
Marjorie is part of a young generation
of Alaska Natives who are trying to
revive cultural traditions once shunned
by outsiders and missionaries in Alaska
one of the beautiful things about
tattooing is that a long time ago it was
meant to help us survive and allowed us
to acknowledge the the spirits around us
and honor the animals and honor the next
generation but now it's coming back as a
way to heal from historic traumas in the
early 1900's Christian missionaries in
Alaska had banned traditional indigenous
practices like tattooing and dancing
they really truly believe that our way
of living was demonic you know was we
were heathens our ability to come
together as a community was was broken
so there's this generational gap of
knowledge that's missing within our
communities and that includes how we
raise our children how we provide
ceremony and ways that we grieve in a
healthy way I got my traditional chin
tattoo in 2012 and that's when I
graduated here at the University of
Alaska Fairbanks and my mom was like
yeah
and I've been my grandma was like oh no
no baby girl you got such a beautiful
face don't do it so there was strong
discouragement by my grandmother but she
was she was one of the first generations
to go to boarding school she had that
mentality of you know that's that's a
tradition our ancestors did but that's
not a tradition we do now I started
learning how to do traditional tattooing
two years ago and before I'd learned
there had been about I mean I can count
the ladies on who had traditional
tattoos like on one hand I wanted to
give other women an opportunity to get
their traditional tattoos in a
traditional way because there was there
wasn't that opportunity back in 2012
they just didn't want to go to a tattoo
parlor they wanted it to mean more I
realized that it was much more than just
putting ink into the skin that it's a
really powerful ceremony one of the ways
that we made the ink to tattoo is with
our seal oil lamps we call it nun up in
our language it means like I feel like
when it dances it kind of feels like our
ancestors are there with us
but it was good being a woman in Yui
tattooist is very powerful video the
chin tattoo is only done by women not by
men at all it most always means a
signifier of strength and women hood you
know becoming a woman feeling strong
enough to be able to be to support a
whole family being able to provide for
your community you know being a strong
member of society that's what getting
your chin tattoo means
[Music]
okay all done
[Laughter]
[Music]
I feel so different they feel like yeah
different it's a whole different me one
of the things that has really driven my
journey to doing traditional tattooing
and learning cultural skills is because
there was a need for that even now even
though the generation now we feel like
who are we what are we what are we doing
in this world you know and you could see
that with the devastation of alcoholism
and suicide it's still very prevalent
within my region and the regions across
the Alaska and not even just Alaska just
indigenous communities that have been
colonized you know so being able to
reclaim that and change it to where we
see fit is powerful dancing is supposed
to have a story that goes along with it
you have people singing the story and
you have the dancers doing the motions
that paint this story and they would
have their traditional style of drum
which is a bent wood into a circle and
it's usually has a skin stretched over
it it would either be walrus stomach
skin or whale liver membrane now we're
actually going into a revival of
composing our songs because for a long
time we were just trying to revive the
dancing and singing because it was
banned in places by missionaries you
feel part of it you feel part of the
whole environment around you it's a
community that's coming together to
paint this picture for people to see
[Music]
my mental wellness and my physical
wellness heavily depends on being able
to eat our traditional foods and if I
can't have my smoked fish or if I can't
have our mock duck or our traditional
foods I like I'm sad like I'm physically
mentally sad I'd ask that you bless your
hands so that's the next week contain
Buster family as their friends so it's
hunting and gathering on the line amen
[Music]
learning our languages and being here
thriving and surviving and being
indigenous wearing my tattoo proudly in
this contemporary world is an act of
defiance for our ancestors and saying
thank you for surviving through all of
that so that I could be Who I am today
thanks you guys so much for watching
this video be sure to check out parts 1
& 2 of the series where you can learn
about the indigenous history of Alaska
and what's being done to protect it from
oil drilling